bonjour
dans un instant vous retrouverez le jeu
d'henry kubrick réponse à tout présenté
par carole chabrier et louis besoin
ensuite midi première avec danièle
gilbert qui invitait pour vous
aujourd'hui gilles vigneault et françois
béranger à 13h le journal suivi des
informations régionales
13h50 d'hier et d'aujourd'hui l'émission
de marc brionne et claudine qu'ils
génèrent avec la rubrique ses chers
disparus
nous évoquerons aujourd'hui la fin de la
carrière de luis mariano
14h05 le cndp vous propose une chasse
photographique en forêt à 14h25 dans le
cycle gary cooper qui débute aujourd'hui
et ce pour tous les lundis à suivre un
film d'otto preminger de 1955 condamné
au silence
à 16h05 dans le cadre du patrimoine cet
héritage qui est le nôtre aujourd'hui
pour trois traditions populaires qui
sont la littérature de colportage la
chanson et l'imagerie d'epinal jacques
douai est ici mon participent à cette
émission qui a été tourné dans les
vosges par jacques min enfin à 17h40 la
rubrique à votre service par jean claude
vernier aujourd'hui les femmes et la
retraite
quels sont les droits des femmes en
matière de retraite eh bien nous en
saurons plus un peu plus tard voilà
l'émission d'hier et d'aujourd'hui se
termine sur cette séquence pour laisser
la place à 18h à tf 4 l'émission de
françois bonnes mains et de jacques poux
je vous retrouve un peu plus tard pour
vous parler du reste du programme